[Musique]
le village de l'emploi qui s'est tenu ce
jeudi 7 juillet au port à accueilli des
centaines de demandeurs d'emploi venus
chercher des informations auprès des 90
organismes exposants et associations qui
ont donné vie à ce village
Rémi lagourde vice-président du
département de l'egal insertion à 1000
accents sur le dispositif R+ de la
collectivité c'est important
qu'effectivement que ce village de
l'emploi puisse permettre
à la population réunionnaise au
réunionnaise réunionnais de bien
intégrer le fait que le département
s'engage plus que jamais dans cette
démarche qui consiste à favoriser
l'insertion quand on connaît aujourd'hui
les chiffres aujourd'hui liés au tissu
économique en général et au tissu de
l'emploi nous départements de la Réunion
sommes au rendez-vous à travers nos
dispositifs notamment au dispositifs air
plus qui permet aujourd'hui à travers
les 5000 bénéficiaires que nous avons
apporté à plus de 44% de ces derniers de
pouvoir avoir une sortie durable et un
projet de vie à travers une insertion
pérenne les stands du département situé
au coeur du village présente toutes les
solutions d'accompagnement déployées par
la collectivité
le Conseil départemental c'est pas que
le R+ donc nous apportons aussi d'autres
informations sur le les a dispositifs du
département les aides financières donc
tels que la fi pour
pour donc les bénéficiaires du RSA le
plan 4000 jeunes parrainer le village
donc
on a les âgé qui arrivent après on va
aller un peu au fil du temps à leur
rencontre pour la présenter et puis ne
serait-ce les voir les partenaires pour
se faire connaître aussi pour qu'il
puisse parler
de demandeurs d'emploi aussi on fait les
deux choses donc on les laisse venir et
on va aussi à leurs enfants en fait on
les accueille on regarde leur projet on
fait un peu connaissance et puis dans le
présente le dispositif et aussi qu'on
sait qu'ils peuvent nous contacter avant
après nous leur fournissons les
informations et qui veulent bien noter
leur nom donc on note et ensuite si pour
les recontacter on les recontactera
après selon leur projet leur demande
l'atelier de chantier d'insertion job
dating avec près de 500 postes à
pourvoir et présentation des marges de
création d'entreprise était également
programme de cette deuxième édition du
village de l'emploi
[Musique]